qu'est ce qu'il a c'est quoi son coup de
gueule parler lui parler lui bien parce
que froid et il n'est pas bien mais
alors qu'est ce qu'il a c'est vrai
d'ailleurs on a écrit mon coup de gueule
là dessus c'est très gentil de la part
de production mais j'ai pas besoin de
l'écrire
oh la la j'ai parlé avec le coach vous
déchirez bon que vous ne vient déchirer
ses traits comme 21 allée hier
honnêtement et franchement je n'ai pas
dormi de la nuit
question je vous promets c'est vrai bah
vous marquez pas tout et merci lui c'est
pas t'en sortir hier ce qui s'est passé
toutes les missions ça a été pour moi le
tpm paix de l'humiliation de la première
minute à la dernière d'abord on a
commencé à l'étude non non et bien
beyoncé ça ne dérange pas du tout hier
pour une fois on a parlé d'un sujet
important la politique ça a duré 15
minutes pendant 15 minutes
là bas moi j'ai levé la main pendant 15
minutes vous m'avez regarder pendant ces
15 minutes
et à chaque fois jamais jamais une fois
vous me donnez la parole et pendant les
quinze minutes boy dans vos yeux
t'es gentil la [ __ ] au bout tu es
mignonne quand on voudra ton avis sur la
couleur de cheveux d'eve angeli ou
pourvoi et de musculation on t'appellera
mais quand on parle de politique ou de
chose d'un peu importante je la créa
discussions entre grands on parle pas
avec toi alors que moi et me regarde et
me faisais ça jorna pas maintenant tout
à l'heure on déconne avec toi
moi la politique c'est la passion va la
table tactile à la table des enfants la
dgac soit des ganaches tu regardes mais
oui moi même et sans rien c'est fait
droit constitionnel à 16 ans je
regardais 7 sur 7 mois à 16 ans j'ai
attaqué la politique ne dit pas du tout
à 16 ans vous aviez osaka c'est qu'au
précis non non non pas du tout donc
al'inverse côté des sujets comme ça
appuyez vous sur moi de me [ __ ] là bas
on nous en joue avec tes boules comme
vous l'avez venir soirée là parce que
justement j'ai pas terminé je suis
désolé si je prends un petit peu de
temps alors on m'avait mis à l'eau bout
de la table justement hier vous étiez
pas content regarder je n'aurais pas
fini après moi c'est bon ça va
ouais ça veut dire du prix mais vous non
non non mais là quand même ça ça pousse
si l'on regarde et je ne peux jouer
dehors pour la première fois vous êtes à
côté des boules
alors tu es là bas tout le temps moi je
suis là tous les soirs et franchement
l'important c'est pas la place c'est ce
qu'on me dit oh la la
moi attendent initiatique revient cette
tâche mois ne convient pas et à partir
de maintenant et deux soirées navan si
c'est possible
eh bien ce sera une exigence je veux
cette variable et une taille si je suis
prêt de vous c'est ma plage sud en
première dame ça me va très très bien
également d'homme et exigeante
j'en ai marre les tchèques c'est
toujours avec jean luc mas bim une
petite blague juste voilà que je sais
que c'est pas un pilote on est diffusée
la non mais tu sais quoi ça sera fait ça
fait trois mois jeudi tout comme ça on a
laissé une caméra survole hier pendant
l'émission
est ce vrai que vous avez passé des
missions difficiles regardez et vous
êtes beaucoup plus proche de ces gens là
à aller au bout créé un grand
perso
j'aurais tenu du boulot qui a été fait
par les journées c'est comme partout sur
l autre là il avait sa lente solide pour
aller ranger le bétail
qu'est-ce qui vaut le prix du pire c'est
qu'après du zebra vous continuez voilà
maintenant je savais quoi je finirai
juste la première dame le tchèque ce
avec moi d'accord donc se sont battus
comme c'est l'usagé mais je termine
parce que le tchèque est quoi c'est le
cheng la saison mais j'ai pas envie de
rire
c'est drôle que tu va regarder
on pas que tu aimes bien alors je vais
bientôt me le pire c'est que du coup ça
commence à m'énerver je me suis fermé
j'ai fait la gueule mais tout le reste
de l'émission
personne n'a remarqué marc hé ouais t'es
gentil voyage au final en plus c'est au
final en plus quand on est là bas
pourquoi j'aime pas cette place on
n'existe pas quand je suis ici là il y
avait julien courbet à l'origine d'un
combat il a deux petits pois l'ariel
nouvelles lunettes alors saiban hardin
des poils nardine lunettes
hier je vous le jure comme tous les
lundis a perdu moi je m'étais coupé les
cheveux et les mois il a fait ça lui
alors là cadors sur julien quand c'est à
moi de l'emmener là abîme jean michel
zecca m ouf
sérieux j'étais bien où j'en ai parlé à
jean luc qui était d'accord avec moi
sommes également allés rigolote et
propose pas trop là-dessus jean-luc
est-ce que vous pouvez nous rapporter
les plus connus en larmes de nous il a
tout dit en gros dit oui il m'a pris
pour lacaune à sec les boules et tout ça
il était vraiment pas bien il se fait
une petite beauté sur un toilettage le
dimanche
vous le voyez même pas à l'excès
s'imposait pas remarqué son boulot dit
je vous le dis je ne vous mettrai plus
jamais là bas voilà d'accord et baky
dont émane en tout cas de secours tout
ce qu'on a dit c'est très valorisant
pour tous les maux
il n'a pas besoin d'être proche de moi
pour exister
nous voudrions que jamais avec nous chez
vous je vous dise papa il savait des
maladies deuxièmement sachez que
lorsqu'il ya un sujet ou un débat
intelligent
ouais vous avez le droit de me donner la
parole et vous aurez peut-être des
réponses en conséquence d'accord très
bien vous êtes un spécialiste de la
politique oui je connais bien
alors je suis venu dire au nom du foot
et de moi en quoi c'est trop tard
maintenant nous a demandé qui ce macbook
comment on ce matin au second tour pour
les régionales progression initiale
histoire bayat je vous en reparlerai
voile alors si bon du tout le monde et
ça d'accord tu fais tous premiers
minutes de la fin le public tiennent pas
gagné je peux citer tous les premiers
milliers de places à calmer
non je ferai pas maintenant ce n'est pas
le problème
ministre d'aller au moins trois endroits
ce nom 3les istres actuel mais non mais
si tu n'es pas mon professeur et je ne
suis pas ton élèves jaune
alors on tirait à 12h03 antoinette donné
la ministre s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît ne soufflait pas quatre ministres
actuels à l'évidente et asie
bah pas le premier mais attention hein
on va faire le premier ministre bah
ouais j'en connais plein dilemme alors
non non non mais vous savez quoi
vous savez quoi dans ce bref quand tu
auras un sujet à nouveau sur la
politique vous pourrez m'interrogeais
ministre oui mais je ne vous répond pas
cyril hanouna
aujourd'hui il est contre vous j'ai eu
le courage de le faire vous en faites ce
que vous voulez gilles ce qui me gêne
c'est qu'il ya deux visages de matthieu
delormeau ya le visage de matthieu
delormeau plan niche à l'envers vous mon
beau cyril et cetera juste vous vous
prenez l'orchestré philharmonique était
là
je sais que vous pouvez pas rester toute
édition vous avez un concerto juste
après mais c'est juste mon savoir
d'accord donc avec nine est requise ça
c'est le bon visage le visage lait est
moche je l' ai vu en loge et je ne peux
pas garder ça pour moi ici aussi parce
que matthieu delormeau
il n'a pas du tout fait comme ça acte
d'allégeance en loge où elle a essayé de
nous monter contre vous non il a
prononcé un mot
c'était pas un acte d'allégeance
exactement là il a prononcé un mot je
vous pouvez rendormez vous vous rappelez
oui on descend si je fait un caca
nerveux comme ça vous moquerez plus
jamais ni de mandat sur ma poitrine une
mes joueurs je prends des notes 1
la bombe fait penser à la pomme d'amour
c'est vrai c'est vrai une fois consommés
ils bavent
ce trône on nous a demandé de le suivre
ouais de le suivre ou dans un putsch
dont il nous a dit aujourd'hui c'est un
putsch je vais putsch et cyril hanouna
et bien moi mathieu delormeau
je ne vous suivrai pas un je n'ai pas de
doute mon jeu enfants et personne ne
s'est levé quand vous avez proposé de
faire un coach posez vous les bonnes
questions
c'est pas vrai si c'est le v7 suivre ton
coup de gueule et ben kislev sûrement
push
bon allez
alors tout cas un sacré 10h toi
bon les gars mais vous allez reprenait
le cours de l'émission les grandes
gueules du parking poutou un petit fruit
face à l'espagne annonce à bâle à
ibrahima sy commence à me courir sur
leur image in the second déjà que les
présentations dure 20 minutes
s'il doit faire cinq minutes de
compliments à chacun on va faire quoi
c'est vrai voilà je regrette de ne pas
avoir de voiture parce qu'apparemment
contrepartie